foreign
Chicago hey Adam welcome to the Ramsey
Show
good afternoon thanks for taking my call
sure what's up
so my mom is facing a foreclosure and is
asking me to lend her fifty thousand
dollars to stop this and we do not have
much time I'm looking for uh to get some
a different perspective on how to
proceed with this and what I should do
wow
fifty thousand dollars she's behind on
her payments
yes uh let me give so much as how much
is her monthly payment
uh for monthly payment I believe is
about a thousand dollars
in four years
she has a
mortgage didn't exactly sneak up on her
did it
no it did not it did not why has she not
paid a payment in four years I thought
this was going to work
she's been making a monthly payment on a
HELOC uh with a balloon payment it
reached its maturity date and then it
was all due at once I did not have the
funds so this is she's not behind on her
payment she has a balloon on her e-lock
yes oh okay that's not nearly as
irresponsible but close okay wow all
right so what's the house worth
house is worth around three hundred
thousand dollars and what is the first
mortgage amount
uh I do not have that much information I
believe it's around 200 000 with this
other HELOC at around 90 to 100 000.
I thought you said it was fifty thousand
to pay it off
she's asking me to lend her fifty
thousand she will up put up uh forty
thousand okay she has a ninety thousand
dollar HELOC
yes that's that's called on a balloon
yes and her first mortgage youth you
think the 200 includes that so you think
our first mortgage 110
that'd be about right
I I believe that's the scenario she
hasn't shared all of the information or
been transparent yeah well transparency
kind of comes with that request for 50
Grand
I agree so um
so uh can you give her 50 Grand do you
have fifty thousand dollars
yes that's all that I have okay so
that's why it's 50. yeah
um how old is your mom
uh 39.
how old are you
.
she had you when she was 14.
no you said 39 and 25. 40 44 my
apologies
she's 44.
yes oh okay all right I'm just trying to
catch up here because that my math my
math brain went nuts there for a second
how did you get 50 000 bucks at 25.
that's impressive
saving it
okay I work full time
do you have any idea how long this has
all been going on with your mom
yes I believe last year is when she
began to become aware of the situation
uh she has put it off and not made
progress have they started the
foreclosure proceeding
she went into forbearance and that's
where we are now we are ending before we
aren't she is
correct correct you aren't in this
correct she's in forbearance and
forbearance just simply means she's
paying payments uh so that they don't
foreclose so they've not started
foreclosure what state is she in
Illinois
and why is she unable to get another
home equity loan to pay this one off
with a different bank
no why
she has no income currently
okay why isn't she working
that is a great question that I have
also asked
because here's what we're getting at you
hand her fifty thousand dollars she pays
this thing down
and in 12 months we're right in the
exact same spot we're not going to have
a 90 000 balloon but she doesn't have a
job she doesn't have any way to keep
paying the mortgage already has
like there's
a pattern here that's not sustainable
for her and her life
and uh the question is are we just
giving a drink a drink or are we really
helping someone get sober for the last
time and that's the question you always
want to ask yourself and um
I think you're giving a drunk a drink I
don't hear anything in this pattern
right now that indicates she's going to
do anything there's nothing in this
pattern that is responsible
so if I were advising your mom and she
came to me and told me her story
um I would tell her to sell her house
before it gets foreclosed on
it needs to go on the market this week
with a good real estate agent
you can find one at elp's endorsed local
providers people we endorse in your
neighborhood that are high octane high
protein at ramsaysolutions.com you need
to sell this she needs to sell this
house
she can't afford it she doesn't work
she is she does not want to sell this
house it's a two unit apartment and she
wants to live in one and then I don't
really care what she wants she's asking
her child for fifty thousand dollars
and no you can't give her fifty thousand
dollars
absolutely that is true I will advise
her to that ultimately I've tried to
talk with her and she seems that the old
she's going to take it all the way to
the last uh day of this and that's what
and there's nothing you can do about
that we all have people that we love
that do stupid things
and you and it hurts you to watch them
do things that are hurtful to themselves
you cannot control her actions
and it is not your fault if she chooses
to do that she has options she has had
options like get a job she's had options
like refinance this before her credit
got bad while she had a job and get rid
of this balloon she had options like not
taking out the home equity loan in the
first place she has options now like
selling the house all of these are much
better options than going to your own
son who's 25 years old and asking him
for fifty thousand dollars
right
so let me ask you this okay you're not
married are you
no okay
um can you I don't know if you can get
your head around this but if you were
married
and you had
a little boy
and 25 years later can you imagine
asking your own little boy for fifty
thousand dollars because you can't seem
to get your crap together
I can't imagine doing that I might ask
deloney for money but I'm not saying one
of my kids for money
I just couldn't do it I couldn't I mean
I just there's something there's
something broken here my son went to buy
something the other day at Sonic and he
said
I I just I'll pay and I couldn't allow
it like I it's not his job it's my job
to feed you you're my son yeah and it's
not your job honey you're 25 years old
you busted you're not your job and you
busted your butt to have this money and
it doesn't even fix the problem if you
had 20 million dollars extra laying
around and you wanted to give her fifty
thousand dollars you want to give her
ninety thousand dollars I'd say well we
can talk about how to do that but this
is all you've got and there's just so
much ethically and morally wrong with
this whole conversation
please don't do it please ask her to
sell her house that's what's good for
her too by the way